le nombre de personnes par exemple en
réanimation 3270 cela qui s'affiche mais
c'est déjà plus de près de 60 % des lits
de réanimation et donc si là dessus on a
quelque chose qui monte en flèche
on risque de monter même à des niveaux
plus élevés que ce qu'on a vu lors de la
première vague est ce que le pire est à
venir
oui je viens de dire que onze étoiles au
pire ça quand vous dites le pire c'est
quoi pour moi c'est eux on est passé
très très près de saturer totalement le
système de santé de pas pouvoir prendre
des gens en réanimation qui en avaient
besoin quand on est monté à plus de 7000
personnes hospitalisées en région
parisienne on était vraiment presqu'un
lits disponibles au moment on a fait les
évacuations notre d'autres régions là on
n'imagine pas que ce sera tellement
possible parce que toutes les régions
sont prêts prise donc oui ça pourrait
être pire que ce qu'on a vu au mois de
mars oui mon bon maintenant penser qu'on
va vivre avec ce qu vide on sait pas
trop s'il va continuer à faire des
nouveaux variants ou au fond s'il va
finir par s'arrêter parce qu'il n'a pas
tant de possibilités que ça pour
continuer à pouvoir quand même bien
infecter les gens ce qu'on constate au
royaume uni à l'heure actuelle c'est que
finalement le vario anglais il est en
train d'acquérir une mutation qui avait
aussi été sélectionnés en afrique du sud
donc ça ça laisse à penser que peut être
s'est il est un peu obligé d'aller dans
cette direction mais après il pourra pas
aller plus loin
alors si c'est le cas ben on va réussir
à contrôler la situation
s'ils continuent à évoluer au sénat etc
mais ça on peut pas savoir entre les
deux pour l'instant parce que on peut
vraiment pas prédire de quel côté savall
de nicolas pour pour vous parce que
c'est quand même votre métier depuis
très longtemps vous êtes effectivement
une sommité quelle est l'origine c'est
une bonne question c'est vrai parce que
on comprend pas ouais c'est vrai alors
assez probablement servient des chauves
souris
on ne sait pas si c'est passé
directement ou si c'est passer par un
autre animal intermédiaire mais c'est
assez souvent que les épidémies
finalement elle elle passe de
l'animal à l'homme par exemple c'est
comme ça qu'on explique l'épidémie
d'infection à vih virus qui existait
chez les singes et qui sont passés dans
l'espèce humaine à peu près dans les
années 1930
donc là pour l'instant on n'a pas
totalement décrit la shell
on est sur le côté chauve souris ouais
on est sûr que maintenant c'est chez
l'homme on sait pas bien décrire ce qui
s'est passé entre lui même exactement où
et quand ça s'est passé mais c'est quand
même le plus probable je vous êtes une
madame une spécialiste mondiale de la
lutte contre le sida ou le
téléspectateur c'est vraiment une
sommité absolue sous de la référence en
matière de lutte contre le sida
vous avez traquer le vih justement
depuis des années est ce que vous pensez
que cette co vide pour être durer aussi
longtemps être aussi difficile à
combattre que ce vih non déjà envoyé
pour le vih dont on a découvert son
effet épidémique dans les années 80 eh
bien on n'a toujours pas de vaccin qui a
longtemps après la finalement de façon
assez spectaculaire et un parent bien
plus rapidement que jamais auparavant on
a réussi à développer des vaccins et y
compris des vaccins qui vont pouvoir
relativement facilement s'adapter aux
nouveaux variance en tout cas lorsqu'on
voit pour l'instant n'ont donc c'est
assez différent malgré tout est dans le
passé les grandes épidémies de maladies
respiratoires
ça fait ça fait des crises qui ont duré
deux trois ans et puis finalement après
on a trouvé un espèce de modus vivendi
ça voudrait pas dire qu'il n'y avait
plus aucun dommage mais c'était quelque
chose de beaucoup plus limité alors
malgré tout c'est ça qu'on peut espérer
qu'il va arriver